Ukraine and us cannot be divorced by anything, everything that is
most precious lies in a hiding place under the mattress,
there passports have faded in the sun with a cutting board, the
flag We will meet again on
Taras's birthday, we will cut your
claws, we will break your paws, you thought that you
would crush us, but the character of the Lugansk
steel, Volya cast iron, you ask Why are the wounds of the
dissection sewn up again  we will meet again there where the
enemy is still standing and the past is
really not worth crying, the day will not come
Dawn will break again on the vanguard we will
return home mother I have come we are still in the
stomach this means the show continues there where
yesterday was dark tomorrow there will be
light we are the occupiers from here  let's sweep
strong where he stood yesterday Pushkin
will be hungry stripes in the sky left dry
wishes Remember this night the wind is cold
from the east plucked the apricot blossom from the tree
sown you are hitting the hail I'm not talking about the weather
but in spring throw a wreath on yourself This
forest
tonight the wind is cold  from the east,
you plucked your crops from the tree at the scythe, the hail
hits.  hey laziness, I
remember the walls, the cold basements, I think
that there will be more, even if there will be more at all,
we will still meet in the finals, remember
Luhansk is Ukraine, not Somalia, you
ask me where is the border to my border, I will
answer my Rubicon, there is the border of
Luhansk  happiness will return with them,
we are all Unbreakable like a bracelet with a coat of arms, not
wrists And if we fail,
our children will succeed It's time to quote the
town hall Roma the more now the
less you will have to beat later and the
sooner all my land will return home
Tell me if there is  the rye whose the mowing
Why live there where in the spring the rye does not bloom
you are here uninvited guests And we are
local we are made of steel we are made of
bricks tonight the cold wind from the east
has torn the apricot tree from its seed
you are hitting the hail I am not talking about the weather but in the spring
Vilkhivka with whom is this forest
tonight, the cold wind from the east tore the
bricos from the tree without your sowing, the
hail is hitting me, I am not talking about the weather, but in the spring
Vilkhivka will throw off this rain
[music]